and we go to the workers who
represent the different industries
that work inside the casinos and they are
different we have a meeting of a
collision board of people a committee
formed this committee is made up of
different unions the unions of the cia
and the unions of the  culinary union the one
of the bar tenders the union of the national
nor air session the union of the centers
and acsi to the workers of auto
workers
to these workers together of those
unions are affected 87 thousand people
are affected right now with the pandemic
and we are  beating
the clark commissioners or that they protect their
jobs that they protect their jobs and
that these workers can have
peace at home knowing that at the end
of this crisis that we are
experiencing their work will be
waiting for them  and we are asking them to
have the right to return to
work after the crisis and if they
start calling workers to
call  to the worker who was before to
work to the places when
the pandemic situation begins to be better